you
in my lab we've been working on tissue
engineering of both blood vessels and
lungs for the past six years that I've
been here our goal is to take cells from
the patient or from a cell donor and use
those cells to grow brand new tissues in
the lab that that can function after
they're implanted in addition to being a
bioengineer i'm also an anesthesiologist
my specialty is working in the intensive
care unit taking care of patients who
have severe disease a lot of my patients
have vascular disease or lung disease
where their blood vessels or their lungs
really don't work very well my goal in
doing the work that we're doing is to
develop techniques so that we can grow
new tissue replacements for patients
with severe disease I first got
interested in trying to grow new tissues
when I was working in my anesthesia
residency in Boston in the early 1990s I
was encountering patients that had
terrible vascular disease and had no way
of replacing or repairing their damaged
arteries these patients suffer heart
attacks suffer problems with their limbs
and and other organ problems and so I
became really interested in trying to
harness what we know about how new blood
vessels grow trying to harness that
information and use it in the laboratory
so we could make new blood vessels for
patients I got interested in tissue
engineering because it's really a
combination of a lot of different areas
of science and medicine so for example
if you want to grow a new tissue in the
lab you have to understand about biology
and medicine and disease but you also
have to understand about physical
principles and and engineering and
mathematics in some cases my scientific
training as I was coming through college
and graduate school was pretty broad and
so I had a lot of training in these
multiple different areas what's exciting
about tissue engineering is I'm able to
pull all those areas together in a way
that can create new therapies one day
for patients I think for anyone who's
involved in
medical research the hope is that the
things that you develop or learn will
one day help patients and that's my goal
too I would hope that one day our
engineered blood vessels can be
implanted into patients in fact we have
a clinical trial that's being planned
overseas that we hope will be begin in
the next six months or so with the long
work I also hope that one day these
engineered lungs may be able to help
patients with severe lung disease
although I think that's probably decades
away
you